CA: Y entonces, creo que el país sufrió su primer ciclón,
y está conectado, ¿no? ¿Qué pasó?
AT: Bueno, estamos en el ecuador,
y estoy seguro de que muchos entienden que al estar en el ecuador,
estaríamos en las calmas ecuatoriales. No se supone que tengamos ciclones.
Nosotros los creamos y luego los enviamos al norte o al sur.
(Risas)
Pero no se supone que regresen.
Pero por primera vez, a principios de este año,
el ciclón Pam destruyó Vanuatu,
y en el proceso, sus bordes tocaron
nuestras dos islas más meridionales,
y todo Tuvalu estaba bajo el agua cuando el huracán Pam golpeó.
Pero en nuestras dos islas más meridionales,
tuvimos olas en más de la mitad de la isla,
y esto nunca había sucedido antes.
Es una experiencia nueva.
Acabo de regresar de mi distrito,
y vi estos hermosos árboles que habían estado allí por décadas,
totalmente destruidos.
Así que esto es lo que está pasando,
pero cuando hablamos del aumento del nivel del mar,
pensamos que ocurre de manera gradual.
Viene con los vientos, viene con las olas,
por lo que se puede ampliar,
pero lo que estamos empezando a ver es el cambio en el patrón climático,
que es quizás el desafío más urgente
al que nos enfrentaremos antes que el aumento del nivel del mar.
CA: Así que el país ya está viendo los efectos ahora.
Al mirar hacia adelante,
¿cuáles son sus opciones como país, como nación?
AT: Bien, he contando esta historia cada año.
Creo que he visitado varios...
He estado viajando por el mundo para tratar de generar conciencia.
Tenemos un plan, pensamos que tenemos un plan.
Y en una ocasión hablé en Ginebra
y había un caballero que me estaba entrevistando
en algo como esto,
y le dije: "Estamos buscando islas flotantes",
y pensó que era divertido, pero alguien dijo,
"No, esto no es gracioso. Estas personas están buscando soluciones".
Y he estado buscando islas flotantes.